yo what's up guys I'm cute I love grits
and today we're gonna make up my uncle
who's famous shrimp sausage fingers
my relationship with Uncle whom he's
like for our family he's the go-to guy
if your car is messed up you go to uncle
food if you want some food you go to a
pool he's the best cook in the family by
fire actually was staying with him when
I was traveling a lot going back and
forth to New Orleans and I went out
there and just had a bunch of fair food
like spices and you know shrimp seafood
and when I came back home I was like I
have to I have to get this like we got
to do this like a fool like we'll be
what we gonna do what could we make you
know that we eat on a regular basis
that's kind of like that and grits for
us was a everything like we'll make
grits everyday grits eggs sausage grit
says bacon but we want to mix it with
New Orleans it was kind of like you got
to add a lot of zing in there and there
was shrimp sausage and grits some of the
best memories I have eaten shrimp and
grits with my uncle cool is definitely
just the conversations we will have
during the cooking process and also
during eating like it would always be a
moment for us to just kick back
uncle Pooh is definitely the homie
forever in the recipe I mean for one
just to add shrimp and sausage it's like
such a New Orleans thing in my opinion
the whole seafood with the spices you
get a little bit of like spiciness and
burn your mouth a little bit depending
on how much cayenne pepper you put in
there I'm not sure why anybody wouldn't
eat grits that is like that's a
necessity shrimp and grits is what you
go to for comfort and that's the
actually like the vibe that uncle fool
gets out so you eat it got to be
comfortable you know no stress no
problems that day oh I need to map out I
get a little scoop here
oh my god
thank you and poopoo oh yes
[Music]